[Music]
michael is in florida hey michael
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it sure what's up
hey so i just want to get your take on a
situation of mine um
so i'm 28 years old uh i'm a uh
i'm married we have one kid and uh i
wanted to
know what you think about this situation
i'm gonna be
uh planning on going to pa school it's a
graduate program for a master's
right now i am working full-time and in
school full-time
and i am going to be finishing my
bachelor's degree uh
in december and what uh with xero it's a
ucf and interdisciplinary studies but
it's to fulfill prerequisites for pa
school
yeah i got that um i won't have any uh
student loan debt i pay for school
straight out of pocket
good um so right now my wife and i we do
have the savings
um we the only debt we have is a car
payment but we're gonna be paying that
off within the next month or so
um so i just wanted to know what do you
think
to to pay for pa school because when i
go to pa school i'm gonna have to quit
my job unfortunately due to the high
demand
uh required on the workload um do you
think that
it would be wise to use our savings to
pay for pa school or do you think
uh we should take out any sort of
student loans i've never told anybody
take out a student loan
in 30 years of doing this show yeah
and i wouldn't i would not go to pa
school
if i had to do it with a student loan
yeah
but you don't have to you got your money
in savings to go
yeah we we do stud man i mean that's
impressive
yeah listen if you don't believe in pa
school enough to pay for it out of your
savings you shouldn't go
amen to that yeah i really appreciate
that yeah and you know it's um
well it's something that i've prayed uh
long and hard about and uh
the job i'm in is very it's a blessing
um you kind of knew how
what i was gonna say didn't you i did
yeah
yeah i did your videos a lot and i um
yeah i've been kind of injuring them in
that
i've been kind of studying and i was
kind of coming into this expecting
to know yeah but not only did you know
what i was going to say you also know
i'm right
um you you have done an incredible job
sir
saving up your money to go get a great
degree pa
is a wonderful degree field go
be what god designed you to be and pay
for it he gave you the money to pay for
it
don't go into debt